retour en france avec cette
manifestation de femmes de chambre de
l'hôtel ibis de batignolles à paris
elles sont en colère en rassemblement a
eu lieu ce matin elles sont en grève
depuis 20 mois pour demander de
meilleures conditions de travail dans
cet établissement du groupe accor les
précisions sur place de notre reporter
bassin chebbi elle était venue nombreuse
aujourd'hui le conseil des prud'hommes
dans le 10ème arrondissement de paris
pour attaquer leurs employeurs le
sous-traitant stn mais également le
groupe accor et l'hôtel ibis et des
batignolles concernant leurs conditions
de travail
la nature de leur contrat de travail
mais également des faits avérés
d'harcèlement sexuel encore
d'harcèlement au moral l'audience avait
débuté à 10h30
ici en présence de leurs avocats le
groupe accor a refusé de reconnaître
l'existence de contrats de travail je
vous propose d'écouter m benachour
l'avocat de ces femmes de chambre le
groupe accor refuse de reconnaître
l'existence de contrats de travail avec
les personnes les femmes de ménage qui
travaillent pour lui c'est à dire ses
salariés et en conséquence une audience
de jugement est fixé au 13 juin
pardon 13 décembre 2021 le contrat de
travail officielle c'est justement avec
le sous traitant et tout l'enjeu du
procès c'est de faire reconnaître le
vrai lien de subordination c'est-à-dire
avec l'accord larchitecture juridique
lent chez votre l'enchevêtrement
contractuelle entre les trois sociétés
entre accor l'hôtel et le sous traitant
a pour objectif justement d'externaliser
l'illégalité de sous-traiter la
discrimination
toutes les choses que accord ne souhaite
pas faire parce qu'il souhaite réduire
les salaires parce qu'il il fournit des
conditions de travail très très dégradée
bien il ne peut pas le faire donc il le
sous traite enfin on reste bien
évidemment optimiste dans la déception
c'est d'avoir aujourd'hui encore une
fois le refus le déni du groupe accor
c'est véritablement le groupe accor qui
est l'employeur de
de ses salariés c'est une victoire donc
en demi teinte pour ces femmes de
chambre qui était venue nombreuse
aujourd'hui accompagné bien sûr de
nombreux soutiens d'autres femmes de
chambre mais également des syndicalistes
notamment de la cgt et puis et des élus
on a pu notamment rencontrer eric
coquerel de la france insoumise des
rassemblements organisés ici des prises
de parole avant cette audience qui a
commencé dans les alentours de 10h30 à
l'issue de cette audience on a pu
échanger avec certaines d'entre elles
qui ont déclaré que le combat continuera
tant que la reconnaissance de la
précarité de leur contrat travail de
leurs journées à rallonge ne sera pas au
reconnu elles continueront bien sûr le
combat jusqu'au 13 décembre prochain une
grève avait déjà été entamée depuis
juillet 2019 et continuera jusqu'à cette
date du 13 décembre 2021 lors de cette
audience de jugement dans la sphère des
femmes de chambre de l'hôtel ibis des
batignolles